では よろしくお願いします
はい 今日のテーマはこういうテーマで
ブッダのユーモア活性術ということで
これはほとんど仏教の世界では試したことがないテーマなんです
お釈迦様はすごい真剣
真面目ということで もういろんなことを禁止しているのではないかとか
固定概念がございます
例えば仏教についてNHKの番組なんかあったら
決まりのフレーズがあって
それを全部ダラダラダラダラ流すんですね
南方仏教というのは厳しい戒律がありまして
もう大変閉鎖的な世界であるとかね
実際行ってみたら これ違うとわかると腹が立つみたいですね
何やこれと 自分たち言う通りにやりなさいとそこまで言ったりするんで
この固定概念のおかげで
日本の社会でもね もういろいろタレントさんたちにね
いろいろキャラクターつけてあげるんですよ
それから 本人にどんな才能があっても
これはもう通じません
決まった決まってくれたパターンで頑張らなきゃいけないんです
だからもうそんなに長持ちはしません
そういうことになります
だから仏教はお釈迦様が本当にユーモアを持っていたのかというね
誰も調べたことがないんです
あの バチカンの方で出しているホームページでは
いろんな宗教に対していろんなところを調べて調べて
かなりのデータがあるところですけど
そちらに他の宗教についても書いているところで
仏教に対しては当然悪口の当たり前のことでね
悪く書いてるんですね
かなり前読みましたけど
昨日とかは最近は調べてないんですけど
まあ世界の中で仏教はこのペシミスティックであると
ペシミスティックというのは悲観主義かなであると
すべては苦であると 一切は特異だから
当然ペシミスティックに決まってるという態度なんですね
そういう研究した人は人がいろいろ調べて書きながら
しかし 何と言ったっても
世界で一番明るいといえばそのグループではないかなと思いますよと
で ペシミスティックな
いわゆる悲観主義な宗教なんですけど
実際みんなかなり明るいんだと
これがわからないみたいですね
でも まあ第三者にね 他の宗教を信仰する方々にはそう見えることは
まあもうそれは避けられないんです
生きることは苦であるということは
ペシミスティックではなくて事実なんです
逆に私たち聞きたいのは
じゃあ楽ですかと 生きることは何か楽なところはありますかと
で なんで頭がごちゃごちゃで事実わからないだけで
例えば我々一般人だからね
そんなお金もないんだから
すごい金持ってる人のことは羨ましいな
さすが楽しいでしょうなと思ったりするんだけど
肝心な本人にとっては人生はそんな楽なものじゃありません
私たちは何の権力もない一般人だから
皇室の方々やら イギリスのバッキンガム宮殿にその皇室の人やらね
物産やらね そういう権力者を見てね
なんてすごいな 羨ましいなとかね
実際はそうじゃないんです
そういう人々はもうすごい態度で生きているかもしれませんだけど
本人にとっては人生は楽じゃないんです
だから誰も楽じゃないんだから
もうなんでそれ否定するんでしょうかね
それにお釈迦様はからかいちゃうんですよ
無知だと 自分が無知であることは表現しているんだと
あべこべなことを言っているんだと
まあいい加減にしろよと
ありのまま物事を喋りましょうと
そういうことで 仏教は
特にお釈迦様がかなり面白く語っていたんです
だから 当時インドではお釈迦様はかなり人気あったんです
ものすごい人気がありまして
どこかにいらっしゃると聞いただけで
もう宗教に関係なくみんな行くんです
言って あの難しい話を聞いて理解して帰るんです
なんで難しい話をそんな簡単に理解したんですかね
もう世界変えたんだからね
たった四十五年間の仕事で
ものすごく厳しく 難しいことを人に制限
リミットばっかり もう戒律
規則ばっかり喋っていると
当然嫌がりますよ 何か秘密はあるんです
なんでそんなに人気あるのかということで
一つはお釈迦様のこの軽さなんですね
すごい気楽に こちらには黒く見えます
そちら見えますかね だいたいスライドは
はい それから仏教 一応まあまだ行ってないんですけど
まあ経典にもそれなりのユーモアがあると
まあ先程に先程で喋ります
では そのユーモアはどんなものかと先に考えた方がいいんです
無駄話と笑いというテーマで
世間のユーモア術とはほとんど無駄話でではないかと言えると
ほとんど無駄話なんです
皆様方 漫才とかいろいろ話術のところに行ってね
聞いてお金払って聞いたりするでしょうに
面白いんで 聞いてる時は
でも別に何も役には立ちません
それから同じストーリー繰り返し繰り返し言うだけで
それが面白くない この場でこうしますよ
この場でこうしますよとか
もう聞いてる人も知ってるんです
そろそろあの場面が来るでしょうとかね
これで笑ったりするんです
しかし 役には立ちませんので
無駄話にはなります 社会の問題
人生の問題などをネタにして笑いを取る才能のある人の場合は
一概に無駄話と言い切れません
しかし この笑いに大変な特権があるんです
社会の状況を分析するとか
問題に対して何か語るとか
最近 NHK で見たことなんですけど
このいろいろ税金のシステムが変わったり
もういろんなもう社会のいろんなことが変わったりするでしょう
あの家のローン ローンを払う場合はどうするかとか
あれやこれやとか もうあの
何といいますか 確定申告する場合はどうすればもうたくさん戻ってくるくれるのかとか
そういうややこしい 一般的に理解できないいろんなテーマを扱って番組を作るんですね
その時 必ずもうこの笑いの人々を出すんです
覚えているのはガッテンという番組なんですけど
まあ大事なポイントを言ってますよ
別に我々の勉強になるもの
そのまま言っちゃうと面白くない
誰も見ないんです それはすごい笑いのタレントさんたちがプレゼンテーションするんですよ
そうなってくると 楽しく内容も学んでしまうんです
ほとんど覚えてしまいます
それでまあ それは NSK のディレクターたちが考えたもので
他の日本の社会を見ても
いろんな社会の問題を扱って
ギャーギャーと喋ったりして
あの みんな笑わせて 同時に何かポイントを言うというね
あの 何でしたっけ？昇太さんでしたっけ？何グループでしたっけ？あれは
えっと え？爆笑問題という二人
まあその結構勉強して調べて
社会の問題を出すんです
かなり派手に そうすると怒ることもなく
聞く人々にもニコニコと笑いながら
もう普通だったらすごく腹が立ってしょうがないという
大変不公平な問題とか扱って喋ったりしますよ
それでも そういう怒り憎しみなく
ニコニコと笑って問題を理解することができるんですね
やっぱりそういう人々は本当に笑いの才能があるということは言えるんです
ただ 笑いを取るという目的だけでもないんですね
結構厳しく研究するんです
生きる上で役に立つ 苦しみを和らげる
問題を解決する 笑いは無駄ではありません
ですから 本当は笑いは無駄なんですけど
それが有効に使える 人間の役に立つために使えば無駄話になりません
なんで無駄話っていう話を持ってきたかというと
仏教では無駄話はダメです
無駄話は悪いんです 罪です
無駄話で人の幸福がなくなるんです
頭が悪くなる まず時間がものすごく無駄に浪費する
それから大事なことを考える能力が無駄話で失っちゃうんです
だからかなり損なんです
大体ちょこっと時間の余裕があれば
みんな無駄話したがるんです
これ危険です 時間の余裕があったら
何か役に立つこと 何か勉強になることをした方がいいと思います
で 頭が本当にいい人にとっては
別に何をやったっても
そこから何か学ぶことができますけど
そうできない人は やっぱり時間は有効に使った方がいいんです
だから時間有効に使わないことは時間の浪費で
人は不幸になるし そういうわけで
仏教は無駄話はもう悪のセットの中に入れているんです
次に品格と笑い 品格のない言葉をうまく使用することで笑いを取る人もいるんですね
これは皆様 私よりは結構知っていると思います
私は日本語で一般日本語以外は他あまり単語知りませんだからね
常識的に公では言わないと決まっていることを工夫して話して人を笑わせる
まあいろんなもう言ってはいけないこと
言わないこと まあ堂々と言ったりして
それでみんな笑っちゃうんですね
これちょっと間違ってますね
聞いてる人は常識はずれであることについて笑うのですが
役に立つことは何もない
聞く人ですね うん それで常識
なんか聞いたことがありますけど
テレビなんか下ネタと
なんとか単語あるみたいですね
で そういう風な ちょっと品格に欠けているというか
普通の人にはちょっと言いにくい
言うとかなり立場が悪くなるんです
しかし それも堂々と言える人々はいるんですよ
そこもそれは才能かもしれませんだけど
無駄話は無駄話なんです
品格がないです これも世間でよく使う技なんですね
で よくアメリカ映画とかね
まあかなりユーモア たくさんね
ユーモアがあるんだけど
私は見るときは一応英語の会話を聞いてるんですけど
すっごく汚い単語ばっかし
ものすごい汚い単語 汚いことを言っちゃうんです
で それは適切に日本で日本語にしていますけど
そのままはやってない
やってないんです はい
そういうことで 笑いと品格という問題もあります
それで仏教から言えば
やっぱり品格のある笑いの方が結構才能が必要になるんです
仏教で見られるユーモアは
はい これから仏教の世界に入りましょう
それで今言ったことはないんです
無駄話はしない 品格がある
役に立つ 何か教えてあげる
その特色でユーモアがあるんです
仏教が語る内容は 一般的に人は考えない
発見もしない 常識範囲を超えている真理なんです
お釈迦様を教える内容は
もう一般の人には想像もできない
いくら踏ん張っても発見できない
かなり厳しい内容なんです
仏教は それを優しく 柔らかく
順を追って丁寧にに言わないとついていけないんです
だから仏教には自然に語り方というものは必要なんです
ただ 人の人気を買うためじゃないんです
大勢の人々を喜ばせるためじゃないんです
これ 内容自体難しいんです
だから この学校ででも
子供たちに何か教える場合は
子供たちは聞きたくはないし
勉強もしたくないし それであらゆる工夫をして面白く
楽しくプレゼンテーションしなくちゃいけないんです
なぜかというと 君たち勉強したくないんですか？ああ
よかったよかったと それでは話はダメでしょうに
勉強したくないんだ じゃあよかったよかった
じゃあやめましょうとは
では話になりません 勉強しなくちゃいかない
だから勉強せざるを得ない
学ばなくちゃいけない環境を作らなくちゃいけないんです
それであらゆる工夫をするんですね
いわゆる英語ではティーチングメソッドというね
教える方法 方法論ですね
だから仏教のユーモアというよりは
仏教っていうのは この教育学的にかなり学べるものはものすごい大量にあるんです
理由もあります お釈迦様が自分が世界一最高の師匠であると自分でおっしゃっているんだから
それはその通りでもうすごいんです
その能力は 教える能力は
お釈迦様 それはどれほど大事なことかというと
世の中にいろいろ奇跡というものがあるんですね
仏教では奇跡と言わない
神通と言うんです 奇跡といえば非科学的な単語で
この神通っていうのは非科学的じゃなくて
自分の心の能力を向上して一般人にできないこと
心のパワーであること
そうなってくると科学的なので方法もありますし
その力身につく 奇跡といえばもう科学的じゃないんです
奇跡ですね だから因果法則に逆らっているんです
だからその単語は仏教では使いません
その代わりに神通という
この神通はみんな驚きます
お釈迦様にもものすごい誰よりもあったんです
しかし それに推薦すると
お釈迦様がそんなことじゃなくて
すべての生命がの腰が抜かすほど
私にはすごい神通があるんだよと
それは何なのかというと
教える能力だよと それはあでさなパーティーは指導の神通という
そういうふうに使っているんです
人を導くことっていうのは並大抵のことじゃないんです
それは何のことなく 簡単にお釈迦様はしてみせるんです
また 学ぶと同時に楽しみ
喜び 充実感がないと脳は開発しないんです
それは仏教はとても大事にするんです
仏教は苦しい 苦しいって言ってるんだけど
心の中の楽しみを探してるんです
なんで瞑想を推薦しているのかというと
この日常で得る楽しみと比較にならない桁違いの楽しみが
喜悦 喜悦感が 瞑想すると生まれるんです
瞑想はそういうふうに教えているんです
だから仏教は初めからも苦行は反対です
かっこつけるなよと あれやった
これやったとかね あんた楽しくいるのかと
今思い出したエピソードなんですけど
これ経典にあります お釈迦様の気に入りというのはちょっと失礼なんですけど
ある若者がいたんです
年の関係でいえば かなり年下のお釈迦様から見れば随分子供の年だと思いますけど
お釈迦様と仲良くする場合は
一応若者で二十歳ぐらいの年齢だと私は推薦する
なぜかというと この子が生まれた時もお釈迦様手に抱っこしたんです
だから名前はハッター
アロっていうのは家の名前で
それに貼ってお手という形容詞を入れてるんです
お釈迦様にのことを考えて
お釈迦様に礼をする気持ちで
釈尊に取られ まあ抱っこではなく手で取っただけなんですけど
これなかなかないケースだから
自分の子供もそうやって取ったことはないんだからね
その子もその子で 本当にすごい性格が良くて
で 大きくなってくるとお釈迦様と随分仲良ししているんです
ある日 お釈迦様に会いに行ったんですけど
冬 お釈迦様に夜過ごすところなかったんです
だから木の下でブルブルもところで
ああ 電気なくても一応喋れますよ
後ろに聞こえるぐらい
ものすごい冬でしょ 寒くて
お釈迦様 毛布とか何も持ってないし
で お釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様にお釈迦様どうなさいましたかと
楽にいたんでしょうかと
この楽にいたんでしょうか？という単語を入れ替えたら
贅沢にいたんでしょうかという意味にもなるんです
ニュアンスだけ そうするとお釈迦さんはそれを言葉を入れ替えて
若者に聞かれしそうにね
入れ替えて あのね 贅沢に生活しているといえば
これ私のことでしょう
ほか世の中で誰か贅沢していますかと
と答えるんです これってわからないでしょ？家もなく
冬 真冬 木の下で 体を隠す
寒いのにもう毛布みたいな
そういうものもなく 我々だったらもうほとんど肺炎になったりとか
朝になってくる 死んでるでしょうね
それなのに お釈迦様は自慢するんですね
世の中で贅沢に言うといえば
これは私のことやと それからまあ
その若者に それはどういう意味か説明してあげるんです
君たちはね この大きな人々とかね
億万長者たちとかね かなりの建物を作って
窓やらしっかり閉めて
かなり分厚いシートとか敷いて
毛でね あのインドにあるあの有名な山羊の毛がありますよ
すごい 今はいないんですけど
ものすごい柔らかくて
そういう珍しい山羊の毛で作った毛布とかかぶって
でっかい枕つけて寝ていると楽しい
贅沢でしょうねと言ったら
あの子はまあ世間ではそれは贅沢と贅沢
贅沢と言いますよと でも聞きますけど
そういう人々は欲で欲が出てきて
ずっと悩んだり苦しんだりするんだよと
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬などなどが出てきて
競争心とかね ずっと悩んだり苦しんだりするでしょうと
無知でいろんなアホなことをして
かなり悩む羽目になりますよと
精神的に悩みのどん底の位置っている人がふわふわしている布団の上でいたんだからという贅沢と思いますかと
いくらでも寝られないで苦労している人がいるでしょうに
お釈迦様は私にはそういう精神的な悩みはひとかけらもないんだよと
だから最高な贅沢を味わっているんだと
そういうポイントを言ったのは
仏教はかなりこの楽に楽しく気楽に生きることが必要だとしているんです
それが脳の中を見るとよくわかるんですよ
脳が喜びがないと成長しないんです
変なものですよ 何か喜び
何か楽しみ 何か充実感
やったぞという気分がないと成長しないんです
だからですよ 皆様は教育世界でもスポーツ世界でも喜びのところじゃなくて
地獄を作ってくるんですよ
スポーツ選手になっても
コーチについたら コーチは殴るは蹴るは怒鳴るはいじめるは
もうもうキリがないんです
よくわかっているみたい
能力向上する方法 ひとかけらも楽しみがないんです
その上 もう責任感ぶち込むは
緊張感ぶち込むは やりたい放題
能力退化するものは何でも提供する
ちょっと楽しみ 喜び 充実感は
それはもうとんでもないと引くんです
言いつつ 仏教に悪口も言いますね
世の中は 自分でわざと苦しみの世界を作って
ブッダの考え方は 心になんとなく楽しみ
なんとなく面白い というものがあれば機能するんです
それなんとなく面白いはダメなんです
本当は面白くてたまらないという風になってこないと
脳は成長しないんです
もう面白くてたまらないと
そうすると 何のストレスもなく脳が開発する
智慧が現れる だから仏道は自体はすごい楽しいんです
はい 次 物事を理解するために
覚えておくために 楽しみという要素が必要です
今説明しました さらに役に立つとわかると学びたくなるんです
役に立つんだそうと 勉強するときはまあ嫌かもしれませんだけど
ちゃんとプロになったところでみんな真剣に勉強するんです
そういうプロのね 知識世界あるでしょう
お医者さんやら弁護士やら
まあいろいろ 弁護士にしたっても
弁護士として もう学生として学ぶときはもう嫌で嫌で
それでちゃんとプロになってからいろんなケースが出てくると
いろんなデータを調べなくちゃいけないんですよ
法律を調べて 過去のデータを調べて
過去の前例はいろいろ調べたりして
もう自分のは弁解しなくちゃいけないんですね
弁護しなくちゃいけない
その時は何のことなく研究するんです
なぜでしょうかね それやらなくちゃ役に立つんです
だからお医者様にしたっても
大学ではもう嫌で嫌でやったかもしれませんだけど
どんどんどんどん自分がプロになって
一人前になって 自分が責任を持つようになってくると
とことん研究したり 調べたり
楽しくやるんです ある大学教授が言ったことなんですけど
あの 自分がね 他何もやらないで
自分の分野の研究ばっかりやっているんだと
それ面白いと聞いたところで
あのね 勉強は気持ち悪いのは学生の時だと
この立場になったらこれほど楽しいことはないんだと
という答えでしたからね
私もやっぱり気持ちはわかります
役に立つということをわかったら
もう誰でもやるんです
だから子供たちに数学を教えたってね
これって役に立つ やっぱりわからないでしょ
役に立つ場合もあるし
立たない場合もある だからいろいろ
半年一回ぐらいは まあ数学のなんとか
あの 何といいますか そういうまあ
テストみたいなものがあったりして
テストではなくて まあその地方の学校全部 1箇所でもう誰か１になるかないかとかね
メダルあげたりとかね
じゃあ今度うちの学校メダル取りましょうとかね
そういう風に試合 試合形式とかなんとか作っちゃうと
子供たち数学自体は自分の人生に役に立つか立たないかわかりませんだけど
この試合で勝ちたいんですね
試合でメダル取りたいんです
そういう強引にでも何かを役に立つということを作ってくれないとやってくれないんです
それは怠け者というわけじゃないんです
脳がそういうふうにできているんです
役に立たないと もう全然やる気がないんです
役に立たないこともやる場合あるんです
その場合は楽しいんです
皆さんはコレクターといってガラクタを集めているでしょ
何も役に立ちません しかし
あのお箸袋とかね これ実際テレビで見たんです
至る所にあるお箸袋を集めているんです
何の役にも立ちません
それ探しに行かなくちゃいけないでしょ
日本中 で 各ラーメン屋さんが自分でデザインしたものを使ったりする場合もありますからね
そういうことで なんであれやるのかというと
まあこれは北海道の方でこれこれやったら
そこを北海道セクション別にカテゴライズして
まあ関西のセクション別に枠組みにして
これは関西のラーメン屋さんの箸袋とかね
これは関西の料亭とかね
まあちょっと日本食のやっているところの
こういうこういうものであると
えらくそうにガチャガチャガチャガチャ説明するんです
聞いている人には最悪うるさくうるさくてもう迷惑なんですけど
本人にとっては楽しくてたまらないんですね
だから楽しみ その場合は引き金になるのは
だから脳が動いてくるためには条件２つ
楽しみと役に立つ それは仏教はすごく正しく整理整頓してくれますよ
バカみたく楽しむ バカみたい楽しみはやめましょうと
役に立つことで楽しみましょうと
だから仏教は何か悪いことを言ってますか？楽しいんだからって麻薬取っていいわけじゃないでしょうに
楽しいんだからってアル中になっていいわけじゃないでしょうに
楽しいんだからといってパチンコを依存するなっていいわけないでしょうに
楽しいのは楽しいんだけど
そこでそこら辺でいくらか決まって
こういう楽しみだよと
誰にも迷惑をかけない
自分の人格向上する 周りの役に立つ方法で楽しみを見つかる
それで役にも立ったりして楽しみもあるという
ブッダの説法には この特色すべて揃っているんです
今まで喋った必要な条件
全部揃ってからのユーモアなんです
だから皆様もこれからプロの笑い芸人になりたければ
ブッダのやり方を学んだ方が
一時的じゃなくて 売れ出したら永久的に売れます
笑いは狙いではない これがプロの笑い芸人と仏教の違いところなんです
プロの笑い芸人がとにかく狙っているのは
お客さんが笑ってくれるかないかなんです
時々おじいさんたちが笑ってくれるどころではなくて
怒鳴ったりするんです
お前面白くないよとかね
堂々と言うみたいです
間違ったんじゃないんです
あなたは とかね そうすると
この若手の人々はどんな気分になるのかと
かなり地獄でしょうね
精神的には そう言われると
特にもう家族関係も崩れているし
だからなおさらなんですよ
若者の前でおじいさんたちが並んで座って
芸を見て 面白くなかったねとかね
あちら間違ったでしょとか言われると
まあ父親 おじいさんみたいな感じで
あ そうですかねとかね
あ すいませんねとかね
もう一回頑張ってみますとか言う気分になったら
あの 怒鳴られても全く大丈夫です
よく心配してくれたと
だからじーっと私の話を聞いていて
間違ったところをちゃんとチェックしてくれたって
そういう気分にならない
現代は だって自分の父親とも関係ないんだからね
だから厳しいと思いますよ
それで芸人が腕がいいかないかということは
このお客様の笑い声で決めるんです
なんか似てる番組も真夜中ＮＨＫでもやってるみたいなのに
二 三回見たことがありますね
聞いてる人々はこのポイントを与えるんです
それでも勝敗決めるんです
その場合ははっきりとこの笑いを取ることが目的なんです
手段なんであろうとも
言ってる内容はどんなアホな無知なことであっても
人は笑ってくれるかっていうことで
仏教は決して笑いは狙いじゃないんです
人を育てることが狙いなんです
仏教は笑いは狙っている
論理 理屈を広めたくなる
これ何て言いますか 定説であることを知らせたくなる
論争を好んでいるなどなどを言われると
それはブッダにその教えに対する根拠のない非難だとするんです
よく言われたことなんです
仏教は論理ばっかしで
なんか自分がすごい論理上手上手やと言いたがっているんじゃないかなとかね
それからいろんな人々と討論したりしたことは
当然ほとんど経典 そういう調子ですからね
じゃあ口達者で人と論争することが好んでいるんじゃないかと
そんな話を聞くと お釈迦様はすぐたちまちそちらに行くんです
普段ほとんど興味もないんで
人を言うことには ある人が釈尊がね
あれは理屈で喋っているんだよと
言われて すぐお釈迦様そちらに行って
あんたこんなこと言ったんですかね
はっきり認めてもらったのは言ってないのかと
それでそう言ったならば
どういうわけ？で どうどうと言うんです
自分が理屈で喋っているわけじゃないんだよと
だからお釈迦様が笑い狙っているというと同じことなんです
これは仏教に対する侮辱になるんです
お釈迦様 その時だけ厳しいんです
あんたはね 狙いを侮辱しているんだと
狙いを侮辱すると 次の人生は決まっているんだからねと
真理を語る人を侮辱するということは
大勢の人々の善行為の道を閉ざすことをやめ
覚えておきなさいよと
だから人が持った荷物をやがて必ず下ろさなくちゃいけないし
そのようにあなた方は死んだら必ず地獄に落ちますよ
誰のどうすることもできないんだと
そこまではっきり言うんです
だから仏教は決して笑い狙っているわけじゃないんです
笑いがあるんだけど それは目的狙いじゃなくて
人を育てることが考えているんです
侮辱冒涜になります 故にこのように語る
ではブッダはこのように
どのように語りますかと
わかりますね じゃあまあ日本訳省略した日本訳あります
ルンナミダンビッカリアリヤサヴィナヤヤディダンギータンウンマッタカミダンビッカウェーアリアサヴィナヤヤディダンナッチャンコーマーラカンイダンビッカウェー
アリアサヴィナヤヤディダンアティウェーランダンタヴィダンサカンハシタンタスマーティヒャビッカウェーセートウガートーギーテーセートウガートーナッチェアラン
ゴーダンマパモーディターナンサタンシタマッタターヤ
このアングットルニカイというところから出しました
意味は見ましょうか 比丘たちよ
聖なる戒めにおいては
歌は泣き声のようなもの
歌ってるとあの人は泣いてるんだぞと
あのパンという言葉のからくりもありますけどね
踊りは狂気になったようなもの
いろいろ今あるんで よく見ると
ちょっとその目で見てください
ちょっと今日頭がおかしいんじゃないかなと
長い時間音を立てて歯を見せて笑うことは商人になったようなものですと
情けないと ガキじゃないと
あんた方は したがって
君たちは歌をやめなさい
踊りをやめなさい 真理を理解することで
怒る 微笑みだけで十分ですと
笑うのをやめなさいと言ってないんで気をつけてください
歌うのをやめなさいよと
あれ気持ち悪いと泣いてる
泣き声だと あれは だって本当に泣き声でしょうに
あれが消えた もう二度と会うことはできない
そんな歌ばっかりでしょう
なんだらかんだら酒とかね
本当に私にとっては暗くて暗くて
いいいい加減にしろと
時々プロの方々はもう歌いながらもう涙ポロポロ
パフォーマンスですけど
もう泣いて見せたりまでするんですね
あなた方も泣けと これが喜びだと思ってるみたいですけど
ブッダははっきり言うんです
踊る あれって狂ってるんじゃないの？と
だからそれやめなさいと
それから笑うことでも
長い時間もそれはよくないと
ちょっと笑って笑ってよろしいと
だからまあ笑うことは否定してないんです
それも理屈はありますよ
我々にはなんか笑うことをやめられないでしょ
何か面白くなって笑わないことにする
そうできないでしょ 踊らないことには
それはできますね 歌わないことには
それはできます だから
お釈迦様がいかに精密かというと
笑うことってのは自然に起こりますから
それはくしゃみと同じでどうにもならんです
いきなり笑っちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様はそこをやめなさいと言わないんです
そこは品格よく 何か理解した
何かがわかったそうと
あ わかりました わかりましたと
数学の問題はちょっとややこしい
問題が解けたらできたそうって笑っちゃうでしょ
ああいうぐらいの笑いで楽しみでよろしいと
微笑みは絶えない 悩んだり苦しんだり
怒ったり 攻撃したくなったり
落ち込んだりするべき理由を
仏道の人は 人には存在しない
あのブッダの教え わかったらね
何のために怒るのかねとかね
何のために悩んでいるのかとかね
それ不思議でたまらないんですよ
例えばある男の人がね
私と喧嘩して もうもう家内がもう実家に帰ったんですけど
まあちょっとだから そんなに落ち込んだりする必要あるのかと
なんで悩むか分からないんです
それぐらいのことを悩むんですかと
だってそれ 世の中のごく普通当たり前のことでしょうに
ごく普通当たり前のことで悩むんだったら
今日は雨が降らないと悩めばいいでしょう
落ち込んじゃえばいいでしょ
今日は暖かいと落ち込んじゃえばいいでしょうに
今日は晴れで本当に困ったなとかね
そんなことに困ったりしないと
当たり前のことでしょうに
人生で起こることは何でも当たり前なんです
不思議なこと起こりません
これ なんで悩んだり怒ったりするんですかね
仏教の話を知っている人にとっては
こんなバカなというね
何言ってるんで 例えば
旦那さんがすぐ湯沸かしそうなっちゃって
家に帰る 戻ると奥さんが怒ると怒鳴ると
それに言い返したりとかね
自分も怒ったりとかね
どういう意味でしょうかと
もう怒らないでいると
まあいろいろ解決方法も見つかるし
とにかく仏道の人にとってはそういうのは存在もしないんです
例えば おじいさんがもう最後の時期になっていると
ああ 悲しいとかとかね
ないんです 別に ああ そろそろ時期も来ましたねとか
本当にブッダのお話を理解している人ならば
自分が調べたところでがんだとわかった
あ そう がんですかね ああ
なるほど ということはどういうがんですかね
先生は 先生どう思いますかね
なんとか手の打ち方はありますか？とか
いえ そんなないんです
ああ そうか はい わかった
ごく普通なことだからということで落ち着くんです
では準備しようと そろそろ死ぬんだから
そういう風な すごい気分よく
微笑みは絶えません それに理由またあります
一切は無常であると知っているんです
がんだからといって 末期だからといって
どうせもう死ぬでしょうに
自分が がんであろうがなかろうが
オリンピックメダル取っていようか
予選で負けても どこで
死ぬことは死ぬんだから
理由がなく死ぬよりは理由が知って死んだ方がもっとマシやということになるんです
だから一切は無常であることを知っている
良いものも悪いものも一時的で
瞬間に変わる 消えると知っているんです
奥さんが喧嘩して実家に戻ったんだけど
まあそのうち帰るんだから
ずっといるわけにはいきませんと
で 向こうはもうかなりプライド高くて
もう帰らないように じゃあまあいいや
まあ迎えに行きますと
それで何のこともなく
ごく当たり前のことが起きたような感じで
どういかがですかね？家に帰る準備はもうできてますかねと
いえ 帰ります あ そう じゃあまた来ますからということで
戻って また来ますけど
土曜日来ますですよと
もう仕事がありますからと
じゃあ土曜日まで頑張ってくださいと
そういう調子でやると
何も夫婦喧嘩も何もなく
ものすごく明るく楽しく生きていられます
何でも無常だから 別に
すごい気楽に生きていられますよ
大変だ 大変だ なんでこんなこと起きたんでしょうかとかね
何考えてるんですかね
何が起きたって もうすぐ消えます
逆に 私はなんで幸せでしょうか？なんてついてるでしょうか？とか
やめろよと すぐ落ちこけますから
それですごく微笑み残るんです
明るさだけ残るんです
喜ぶにも泣くにも値しないと
世の中のことは ね これわかると結構楽しいんです
お釈迦様はそれを教えているんです
それから面白いこと それ事実なんです
世の中は無常っていうことは
科学者にも誰にも発見できなかったんです
みんなもう科学者は言ってないんだけど
ほとんど宗教家なんかはまるっきり陳腐感も嘘言ってるんです
永遠 永遠 永遠とか 私は聞いただけでもうなんか鳥肌が立つんです
もし永遠だったら最悪でしょうと
これだったらもうとんでもないんだと
特に地獄に落ちるのは怖がるでしょ
仏教も地獄のことをよくよく喋ってるでしょ
それ一番怖がるのは他宗教の方々なんです
だって地獄は永遠だから
すごい頭が悪いね 神がいて
人間ちょっと失敗しただけで永遠に地獄に落とすんです
あの罪に適した罰じゃないんです
相当頭が悪いんです 普通だったらね
罪に適した罰ですけど
例えば道路で若者がちょっと話し合いになったところで
ちょっと喧嘩になったと
それで一人がちょっと気が短い人がぶん殴ったと
相手を 警察はそれを調べたりするでしょうね
じゃああんた死刑であると
日本の法律ではそう決めません
それぐらいのことだったら
それぞれ何か損害でも与えたのであれば
それなんかお金払わせてもう帰しちゃうんです
裁判にもかけません それにしたら神はそうじゃないんです
自分がいることさえも人間知らないのに
信じてくれなかったら
永遠に地獄に落とすんです
大変です もう頭が悪いというと悪りゃしないんです
とにかく永遠ということはとんでもない話で
ありえないんです そこで私の国では
もうまあ このこれも本当は公で使う冗談じゃないんですけど
まあいろいろ冗談話を作るんです
であるものすごい悪いことばっかりやる人がいて
で 仏教の国だからね 酒飲むのはあまり品格がないしね
もう酒ばっかり飲んだり
タバコ吸ったりして 賭け事をやったり
そればっかりやってる人がいるんですね
普通の人は 村人 物の人々はこいつはもう悪人やと
それである人が あのね
あんたそんなことばっかりやると地獄に落ちますよと
まともな人間になりなさい
そうすると天国に行けるんだよと
とこの人は天国は何があるのかと
地獄は何があるのかと聞いたんです
天国はね 美しい花があったり
公園があったり 歌ったり踊ったり
仕事をする必要がなく
楽しくいられるところやと
地獄はあれはもう何て言いますか
ものすごい火で焼けたり
焼いたり 炙られたり いろいろ厳しいんだよと
それで天国には火がないんですかと
この人 天国にはないんですね
やっぱり俺は地獄に決めました
なんでまた？って だってタバコ 1本吸えないでしょ
ということで やっぱり本人は天国に行くのを諦めたんです
タバコ吸えないんだから
火がなくてね まあ本当に仏教の人々
そんなに地獄地獄と言ったって
そんなにもう  その時なんか落ちたってもね
また良いこといっぱいしてるんだからね
罪が終わったら立ち上がるでしょうと気楽なんです
天国 天国にいたら永遠と思ってないんです
気をつけるんです あれならちょっと天国に行ったってもね
もうなんて言いますか
徳が終わったら 過ぎたらね
また来ますからと あんたは
そういうことで この何でも無常という立場で
それ事実でもあります
本当に何でも無常なんです
それ知っただけですっごく落ち着くんです
楽しくなるんです 悩み苦しみがそれで消えてしまうんです
はい 次に行きます 無常たる現象に執着はしない
執着は不可能だと知っている
仏教の人は無常だから
これに執着したらバカバカらしくてもうダメやと
例えば花火は美しいでしょ
だからといって 誰が花火をそのまま持って家に持っていこうと思うんですかね
不可能でしょ シャボン玉はすごい綺麗でしょ
この太陽の光が当たるといろんな模様を見せたりするんですね
美しいんです では 執着してシャボン玉をそのまま持っていって
家に置物として置いてください
ありえないでしょうに
すぐ消えます では 一切の物事は無常だったら
それに執着することはどれほどバカバカらしいかと
シャボン玉を持っていって
家で置物にしようとするようなことなんですよ
だから執着は失望で終わっちゃう
悩みで苦しみで終わっちゃうんです
仏教をわかっている人は
何があっても本当に無執着で
こんなの執着できんでしょうにと
例えば このホールに執着してみてください
何の意味もないんです
追い出されます この契約している時間が終わったら
だから いる間に楽しげればいいでしょ
別に 雰囲気は周りを見て
あ よかったよかったとか
かっこいいとか 執着しないと楽しめますよ
せっかくだからちょっとちょこちょこっと見ようとか
しかし 世の中を見ると
一時的なものに永遠なもの
ものごとく もののごとく執着して苦しんでいるのです
それで世の中そうじゃないんです
何にでも執着するんです
無茶執着するんです 子供にむちゃくちゃ執着するんですけど
それで子供が二十歳ぐらいになってくると
子供でないんだからね
これで派手に悩んだりするんです
で 金に執着するは 仕事に執着するは
もう自分のものでないのに土地に執着するは
権力 あれこれにいろんなことに執着して
執着して 派手に苦しんでるんです
この愚かさと自分たちの精神的な安らぎを比較すると
微笑みが自ずから現れるんです
だから 仏教の人々にとっては
笑っているため 笑うためには何でもいいんです
だって世間はあべこべでしょ
例えば 風船を持って子供が持って遊んでいて
ちょこっと手から風船
手が緩めたところで風船がポッっと上がったりする
それで子供はキャーと泣いたりしますね
普通の人 ああ かわいそう
なんとかして取ってあげましょうとかね
じゃあもう 1本買ってあげましょうでしょ
仏教徒はニコッと笑うんです
ほら 見てと 執着で笑ってるってことはわかるんで
泣いてるってことわかるんです
なるほど こんなのはどうでもいいのにと
それはこの子にわからないんだよと
ある人に私はお経でも上げて
ちょっと慰めてあげようということである家に行ったことがあるんです
日本で どういうことかというと
この親戚同士でお互いすごい憎しみ合ってるんです
いろいろ財産やらいろんなことがありまして
家族はもう誰も仲良ししない
むちゃくちゃあったら喧嘩する
誰のことも心配しない
それですごい年のこの家族
お母様がいたんですけど
一人ぼっちで誰も面倒見ようともしない
それで私はその人の家に行って
お経をあげて慰めに行ったんですけど
何のためかとわかってます
その人 飼っていた猫が死んじゃったんです
猫が死んだことに 1ヶ月間も泣いて泣き崩れているんです
だから いても立ってもいられないんだと
なんとかお経でもあげて成仏してくれませんかと
私はできますよと というよりも
じゃあなんとか来て いろいろわけもわからないお経をあげてあげますということで
普通のわけもわからないお経をあげたんですけど
まあそれで私はいろいろ喋ったりして
本人は落ち着きましたし
長い間一緒にいたんだと
猫は しかし 自分の大人の息子がいたんですけど
息子とは一緒に生活はしたくないんです
息子も母親とは一緒に生活したくないんです
これは人間なんですね
だから そういうことを見ると
私にとってはかなり面白いんですよ
自分の親のことは心配しないんですけど
もうどうでもいい猫にむちゃむちゃ執着して
精神的にイカれちゃって
私まで行って直してあげなくちゃいけないという
だからこの内心 表面的にはそれは大変ですねと言うんですけど
こんな馬鹿なって楽しいんです
結局は 仏教から物事を見ると
いろいろコマーシャルを見ると
皆様だったら買いたくなるでしょ
私 この買うなよというコマーシャルだって何言ってるのかと
あれこれやると宣伝する
それ見ると怪しいんですよ
ついに発見しましたというんだから
もう体のためにこれものすごい研究して
10年  15年  20年研究して
やっと嘘ばっかりなんです
で まあだから買うなよという話なんです
それ時々 あの 私はもうあの
今 5  6年も使ってるんだわとかね
もう欠かせない もう生きがいとか言ったりする女の人がいるんです
もう 4年も使ってますけど
私は製品はいつ出したとわかると
もうもうたった 1年もないんです
作って 1年もないのに
どうやってこの女が 5年間使っていたんでしょうかと
これもっとわかりやすいんですよ
外国のコマーシャルのテレビコマー
なんていいます あれは
テレビショッピングの場合はもう気持ち悪いというか
もう気持ち悪いというのも面白いということなんです
よくこんなことのこのこ言うのかと
それから外国からいろんなスポーツ器具を売ったりするでしょ
それですごいスマートな人が
もうお腹はびっちりびっしり
もうもう腰回りとかももうすごい
でもどんな健康器具にもほとんど同じ人なんで出てくる
みんな見てないんです
お腹の辺りばっかり見ているんだからね
そこでビフォーアンドアフターという写真もありますね
まあとにかく もう何を見ても買わなくちゃということじゃなくて
笑えるんです 笑ってから
本当にその品物が自分に必要なものであるならば
もう買うんであって コマーシャルに乗って買うんじゃないんです
だから世の中っていうのは本当にもうもうもう笑いいっぱいなんです
何を見ても笑い笑えますよ
まあ十一時ぐらいで電車になんか乗ってみてください
みんな仕事でクタクタ疲れて酒飲んで歩けないんですよ
あちらこけるわ こちらこけるわ
あれですごいストレス
ストレスがなくなって気分がいいんだと言うんだから笑笑えないんですかね
俺が本当に気分がいいんだよと
はい どうぞ勝手にください
ついてくださいと こけたりしてね
それで電車に乗るでしょ
最終電車に 私はもう本当にこの人
自分の駅で降りるのか
終点で降りて朝まで待つのかと
何を見ても楽しいんです
この最近ね 花が咲いて
みんな狂って頭が狂って花見したりいろいろやって
私にとっては花でもなく
これやってるようなおるかな
ことが楽しいんです 楽しくないのに楽しいと思っていることが楽しいんです
すごく寒くて みんなあの
なんかあの火鉢とかね
火鉢とか置いておいて
一周こうしてもう何か焼いたり
ビール飲んだりしてこういうふうにいるんですよ
花見を楽しんでるんで
あれは 私にとってはそれが楽しいんだよ
この無知なことをやっていることが
なおさらそれに気づいてないことをわかるとなおさら楽しいんです
だから仏教から世の中を見ると
本当にお金かからなくていくらでも笑えるんです
はい それで笑いに対しての分析はそれでまあ一時的
あの 初めて調べたんですから
あまりいろいろ参考にする本も一つもないし
で それであの これからあの